They were all going [__] crazy over
these claims. Obviously they don't
actually believe it's crazy, they're
[__] lying.
>> is that it's essentially given Ethan
this free pass to just say or do
whatever he wants in response, no matter
how dishonest it is.
>> Ethan when Ethan talks about it, he says
you would have to eat my
>> participate in the CPS lie, Child
Protective Services lie. I explained it
on the podcast, but the truth of the
matter is it's all a lie.
>> So, finally, the much anticipated,
long-awaited, very long-awaited Kilo
video has dropped. Kilo, for those of
you don't know, was the guy who made he
made a progressive victory video a long
time ago, a Brittany Simon video a long
time ago, and he made a President Sunday
hit piece
that was cited by William Mac. Now, he's
made a pro-Hasan video, if you can
believe that, guys. One that Hasan
himself has even promoted. So, we see
here this tweet, which apparently people
are very upset over, Destiny,
more so than anyone. For the last 5
years, the YouTube Apolitical Commentary
sphere has produced a metric ton of
right-wing drama slop that centered me
as the arch-villain responsible for all
things woke. It even led many of them to
take on a pro-Israel stance. Let's see
that environment shifting. So, I mean, I
I hope so. I can't lie, you know, I
don't think that's a crazy in that
perspective either. And I mean, not all
of it's right-wing, you know, there
there is a lot of right-wing drama slop,
yes, sure, like Pikasaru is like, you
know, that's right-wing drama slop, Wes,
yeah, all these guys are like
right-wing. You know, some of it is more
liberal-leaning and still anti-Hasan.
But regardless, the the core point here
is is true. I don't I don't think it's a
particularly controversial. So, I mean,
I guess let's just let's just get into
the video. Let's just take a look at the
video, guys. Let's see, it's 4 hours
long, so we're not doing it all today,
trust me.
>> This is uh
Is Is this not a little bit Mr. Girl
ripped? Is this not a little bit Mr.
Girl ripped?
The uh
the the whole uh projector aesthetics
thing here. Is that what he does for
like his gender narrative video and [__]
like that?
>> All right, so if you've used the
internet at any point in the last few
years, it means at one time or another
you've probably heard the name Hasan
[__] Hasan, who also goes by HasanAbi,
is 34 years old. He's one of online
politics' largest creators, and he's
known for taking controversial far-left
positions and being very tall.
>> tall. He's tall.
>> I I got to watch one Mr. Girl video.
>> Okay.
>> Hasan is best summarized as being very
passionately progressive,
anti-capitalist, pro-Palestinian, and
overall just having somewhat radical
takes that go against the grain. And he
can occasionally make comments that have
a tendency to make a lot of people very
upset.
>> America deserved 9/11, dude. I'm saying
it. We
totally brought it on ourselves, dude.
Holy
We did.
>> Over the duration of his career online,
while he does have some support around
him, Hasan has gradually become public
enemy number one for a lot of creators
and their fan bases. He draws some
pretty intense criticism from not just
the right, but also the left. And lately
he's even becoming more and more of a
regular target for a bunch of a
political idiot slop channels.
>> Hey, Hasan, you crying stupid Brother,
you are the biggest piece of [__] I have
ever seen. Shut your [__] mouth.
>> The attacks on Hasan range from him
encouraging violence to him being an
anti-Semite to him simply being kind of
stupid, which is probably kind of true.
>> I don't know which is which, dude.
>> Doesn't know where Yemen is.
>> I thought it was on.
>> No.
>> This guy's crazy.
No. No.
No.
>> [__] it, man. [__] it.
Got it.
>> Yeah, this video is not really about
debunking every argument against him,
but a lot of the attacking is coming
from pretty dishonest places. Like the
time people claimed that Hasan urged his
viewers to kill US Senator Rick Scott.
>> Here's what he said. If you cared about
Medicare fraud or Medicaid
>> It's crazy that he starts clicking on
like totally landlocked countries there.
That's the craziest part of it. Like,
geography, you know, I'm not even that
good at geography. I'm not going to sit
there and [__] act like, you know, I
know geography. But, he starts clicking
on totally landlocked countries, and
it's just like they're all You must know
at least enough about Yemen to know it's
not going to be a [__] landlocked
country, dude. Come on now.
>> fraud, you would kill Rick Scott. This
clip got Hasan suspended, and many to
this day believe
>> one of those tests on stream. I'm never
doing an IQ test on stream. I'll never
do none of that [__] Never happening.
Not happening.
>> making a death threat towards a US
Senator. The issue there is that Hasan
is clearly talking to US Speaker of the
House Mike Johnson, who's making remarks
about how much he wants to combat
Medicare fraud.
>> why I'm saying if you cared about
Medicare or Medicaid fraud, you would
kill Rick Scott and not make him uh a
prominent part of the Republican Party.
>> So, Hasan is clearly saying, Mike
Johnson, if you actually cared about
Medicare fraud, you'd do the opposite of
what you've done with Rick Scott because
of how egregious of an offender he is.
>> Anyway, guys, this is pretty video.
>> Well known for conducting one of the
largest health care fraud schemes in US
history when he was chief executive at
Columbia.
>> We We covered this at the time, and this
is one of the most misportrayed Hasan
quotes. It's like so obvious what's
being said, and he's he's being
inflammatory. It's misportrayed, you
know, almost in a way that he could and
probably did expect. But, it's still
just like that doesn't make it any
better to misportray it that way, you
know? It doesn't make it any better for
you to to run with the most [__]
reading of the statement possible.
>> So, to say Hasan was urging his viewers
to kill Rick Scott is an outright lie,
and to say it was any kind of death
threat would also be pretty [__]
stupid. So, that's just one example
>> Terrified of being Wizard of Oz in the
whole image. Yes. Yes. The Where he said
Where he's got He's got a 96 or
something. He just said like
Dude, this is so funny.
>> what are very common dishonest attacks
on Hasan? There are, of course, genuine
criticisms to be made about him, and
we'll go over a few of them later. But,
those tend to get lost in this sea of
total hysteria. The widespread
derangement that people have for this
guy has over time devolved into attacks
on anyone he associates with, calls for
him to be deplatformed, and people have
even become pretty chill with the US
government violating Hasan's first
amendment rights. No, I'm not saying you
can't dislike the guy. I don't give a
[__] The dude preaches socialism and
drives a Porsche. Like, I get it. I'm
not a Hasan fan. I've literally never
even watched a single stream of his. So,
personally, I don't care. But, the
tendency for people to lose their minds
and just make [__] up whenever Hasan is
involved left me wondering,
how did we get here?
Ethan Klein, also known as H3H3, is 40
years old. He has a massive
>> So, I think the a huge portion of video
is just about Ethan, okay? Huge portion
of it is just going to be about Ethan,
[__] Ethan's done. Because a lot of the
Hasan hate is wrapped up in that, too.
So, I was watching some of this earlier,
and I was just sitting, you know, bits
of it. Um, and yeah, I think, you know,
a huge amount of this could be about
Ethan.
>> following on YouTube, and he's a pretty
significant figure in the history of
content creation, going back to the
>> Jewish image of Ethan possible.
>> Ethan Klein, also known as H3H3, is 40
years old. He has a massive following on
YouTube, and he's a pretty significant
figure in the history of content
creation, going back
>> Doing IQ test while revealing your room,
while revealing your hairline.
Why do you post my [__] [__] too,
bro? Why don't you just have everything?
Why don't you just
>> to the early days of react videos.
>> I read a book a day not to show off.
It's again about the knowledge. By the
way, he's got a really interesting
technique for reading books. And when he
says he reads one book a day, well,
let's just say
we'll have to redefine the word read.
Have someone else read it for you.
>> That's awesome. Along with his own
content, Ethan's also well known for
winning a landmark copyright
infringement suit in 2017 filed by Matt
Hoss, whose video Ethan reacted to. That
case was one of the first examples of
fair use for react content being
successfully argued in court. In 2021,
Ethan and his son started a podcast
together called The Leftovers. It was a
political and cultural talk show with a
left-leaning slant, and the show was a
huge success. Until October of 2023,
when a Hamas-led terror attack targeted
Israeli citizens. After the attack,
Ethan and his son went live for an
emotional episode discussing the events.
>> As a father, it's even harder to talk
about. This dude was holding his infant.
It was like a year old.
>> Ethan is an Israeli-American dual
citizen and feels passionately about
Israeli geopolitics. He's also married
to
>> I just I don't take any of Ethan's
displays of emotion as genuine. I just I
can't.
>> who was born in Israel and served in the
IDF. The clients actually even met each
other in Israel. His son, on the other
hand, is passionately in support of
Palestine, and the resulting ideological
differences between the two led to some
on-air friction following the start of
the conflict.
>> Oh, my my my
>> Timing matters.
>> No, I
>> Let's not be obtuse about this. Just
It's just this one point I'm trying to
make. You can't cheer on Hamas, dude.
>> You know what I said in on the day of
the occupation.
>> I know you don't, but like we're being
we're being a little silly.
>> In late October of that year, Ethan
announced that The Leftovers podcast
would go on hiatus.
>> I do feel like I'm probably going to
pause Leftovers for the time being. Cuz
I You know what I mean? It's just I
don't I don't want to talk about it
anymore.
>> And after 61 episodes, The Leftovers
podcast never came back. This is when
the divide started to form between Ethan
and Hasan. Early on, for instance, Ethan
would take issue with some things that
Hasan's chat was saying about him, and
he criticized him for not moderating it
more effectively.
>> Do you care that your your chat is
calling me racist? Do you make any
attempt to modif- to
>> I have not looked at my chat
>> moderate that at all. I have not looked
at my chat at all, but you have
>> opened it, but don't you have
moderators? Do you care at all about
what your audience does about me?
>> people in here right now.
>> Tell I'm just trying to tell you guys
how it feels.
>> It's just crazy. Let's see crying about
the Hassan's chat calling him racist cuz
he's speaking out about Palestinians and
[__]
>> I'm [__] shocked that you don't care
that people in your chat are saying who
the [__] is this child called arrogant
kind as [__]
>> Ethan, you, but there's but there's only
so much I can do.
>> when you're
>> us time, let's not get too bogged down
with specifics. In a nutshell, over the
course of the next year, the divide
between Ethan and Hassan grew larger and
larger. Ethan and the H3 community
believed that Hassan was promoting
extremist, potentially dangerous
viewpoints.
>> Yeah, saving this time in the 4-hour
video.
>> While Hassan and his community believed
that Ethan was becoming more Zionistic
over time and subtly spreading
pro-Israel propaganda. The two of them
would exchange jabs for months, with
Ethan commonly taking to Instagram to
voice his grievances, like attacking
Hassan's moderator and smaller creator
Frogan for her radical views. And
Hassan, in turn, would occasionally
respond on stream.
>> There's a difference between
anti-Semitism and people coming to the
assumption that Ethan might be defending
Israel a little bit and therefore might
have some Zionist opinions because of
the past 12 months centering himself as
he looks to ban prominent
pro-Palestinian voices off the platform
with ridiculous smears that they are
being anti-Semitic.
>> While all this is going on, around the
end of 2024, Ethan also began discussing
a perceived anti-Semitism problem on
Twitch. According to Ethan, Hassan and
his associates are prime examples of
anti-Semitic content being unfairly
allowed on the platform.
>> why didn't Kayla animate his avatar
doing the Phoenix Wright finger wag? I
don't know when he's making a good
point.
>> And he called for Dan Clancy, Twitch's
CEO, to step down. We'll talk about this
part more later, but I did want to note
that this is around the same time that
Dan Saltman, CEO of Red Act, began his
campaign against Twitch's perceived
anti-Semitism problem. By the start of
2025, tensions had gotten pretty high.
To the extent that the H3 show covered
politics, their conversation centered
more so around Israel and anti-Semitism,
rather than the humanitarian crisis in
Gaza.
>> It it feels like we're
it was during the war and the Holocaust.
It's just it's reminiscent of that time.
>> I've always always said like I have no
idea how the Holocaust could happen. It
just makes no sense. And now I see it. I
see how it happened.
>> And Ethan would also regularly take to
Instagram to go to war with H3 Snark, a
subreddit dedicated to A logging and
talking [__] about primarily Ethan and
Ela. And in January, Ethan
>> Classically great move, by the way.
Going to war with some random forum that
doesn't like you. Famously works out
works out amazingly in the long run.
>> released the Content Nuke, a 102-minute
long deconstruction of Hassans content,
including further allegations of Hassan
and those around him being anti-Semitic
and essentially promoting terrorism.
After the Content Nuke, things started
to go off the rails. In March, a pair of
noteworthy things happened to Ethan. On
one occasion, he had a pair of human
skulls ordered online and sent to his
house. And on another, a CPS call was
made to his house after Ethan shared a
story on the H3 podcast about his family
contracting a parasite.
>> This morning, we got a visit from child
protective ser- services. I told this
story on the show a few weeks ago about
how when we adopted Olive, she had
Giardia. And then Sunny started having
diarrhea, so we suspected he might have
Giardia. Seeing as that he's an infant,
he's crawling around, he's putting
everything in his mouth, etc.
>> Then in June of last year, Ethan
revealed that he had registered the
Content Nuke with the US Library of
Congress and that he's filing copyright
infringement lawsuits against Frogan,
Denims, and Casey Tron, three
Hassan-adjacent creators who according
to Ethan reacted to the Nuke in a
non-transformative way.
And that's kind of loosely where we're
at. What started as a political
disagreement has spiraled into three
copyright lawsuits, a campaign to
financially harm Twitch and by
consequence its creators, and a long,
bitter, and kind of pathetic feud where
you will be forced to pick a side. But
before you pick a side, while you may
feel some sympathy for Ethan because of
the very real harassment that he's
faced, or maybe you just agree with his
takes on Israel or anti-Semitism, we
have to make sure we don't forget about
the most important thing in the whole
situation, which is that when it comes
to Ethan's narrative, this is all
complete [__]
If you can look past some of the
political disagreement and analyze the
Ethan and Hassan
>> So, I mean, obviously I agree with this.
I am The most interesting part of this
video to me is how is it going to land
with people that don't already agree
with this. I've said this a million
times. I've said Ethan's got Ethan's
whole narrative is total [__] you
know, I I've I've been screaming this
for a year at this point. I want to know
how someone's not totally sold on that
answers to this. I want to I want to
know how someone who's incentivized to
be a bit more forgiving of some details
in this video or react to this. I want I
wonder whether whether we might whether
we might get a jackpot. Guys, I wonder
whether we might a jackpot.
>> conflict in its entirety, it's pretty
clear that Ethan is an insecure,
neurotic, vindictive liar. And his
crusades against Twitch, and Hassan, and
subreddits, these are all just dishonest
missions to silence people who are
saying things about him that he doesn't
like. What's worse is that this clown
show is being encouraged and facilitated
by a host of hacks and other liars
around Ethan that have attached
themselves to him, sometimes just to
further their own dishonest agendas
against Hassan. Now, normally I wouldn't
really care that much if a bunch of
lying freaks all band together to help
each other out with their controversies.
That's kind of to be expected. But what
elevates my distaste for all this stuff,
and what should elevate yours, is that
standards of behavior that have long
been widely held on the internet are
being totally abandoned, all in the name
of Hassan bad. Historically, things like
lying, harassment, calls to the
platform, or abusing copyright would get
you absolutely torn to shreds. But when
it comes to Ethan and all his yes-men,
everyone all of a sudden seems to be
okay with those things. And it's just
because of who's on the other side.
Ethan Klein isn't the originator of the
mass derangement about Hassan, but his
situation has given some of the most
annoying drama slop tubers the perfect
vehicle to pretend to have political
opinions, escalate their grudges, and in
the process, smash all standards of
behavior for political and commentary
creators. So, today we're going to
recognize some of these creators for
their contributions to this online
culture shift, one where truth doesn't
matter, there are no bad tactics, only
bad targets, and anything goes as long
as you win.
These are the Weaselly Little Liar
Awards.
>> Wow.
>> Starting with Ethan Klein.
>> So, guys, that's just
>> Jesus.
>> So, guys, that's just the intro. That's
just the intro.
>> intro.
>> So, we are how far in now? What? About
20 20-something minutes in.
>> This is a lie.
>> Mhm. Yeah, it is not looking
>> This is a disgusting [__] lie, and
here on the H3 show, we tell the truth,
and soon we're going to be able to do
that. So, I'm really very grateful and
excited for that, because I am honest to
a fault, Dan, I'll have you know.
>> Yeah, I know. I I I'm aware of.
>> I would never I don't lie, but some
people do lie.
>> Name one thing I've ever lied about. You
can't.
I'm allergic to lying.
>> Bro, I'm truthful in every [__]
>> Why have we had that recently? Why have
we had that recently?
>> conceivable way.
>> I feel like I'm honest to a fault.
>> I'm not a liar. I don't believe in
lying. I would never lie to you. I've
never lied.
>> I am not a liar. I have never I feel
like I have never lied about anything in
my whole life.
>> you were more of a liar. It would
probably save us a
>> When I started researching for this
video, I already knew that Ethan had
been dishonest about some things
throughout his feud with Hasan, but I
was a little surprised to learn just how
long of a history Ethan has of
dishonesty, a very clear and repeated
pattern of it, in fact. Now, you'll very
rarely catch Ethan in a direct overt
lie. What happens far more commonly is
that Ethan will kind of just say things.
He makes statements about other people
or ongoing situations as though they're
a fact when he has no evidence to be
saying the thing that he's saying. For
instance, back in 2021, there was this
whole falling out between Ethan and his
former podcast co-host, Trisha Paytas.
During the breakup, Ethan made this
tweet where he claimed that Trisha had
accused him of sexually harassing her,
which it kind of gives off this like,
I'm being falsely Me Too'd kind of vibe,
right? But, in the video Ethan's
responding to, which is this one, Trisha
doesn't really say anything like that.
This video is pretty much just about
Ethan bringing up topics like her sexual
assault, medical history, and other
things that supposedly triggered her.
Trisha responded to Ethan on Twitter by
saying she didn't even think he'd
watched her video. And given how far off
he was, it's entirely possible that
Ethan just read the title and went nuts.
>> But, I've never seen any Trisha Paytas
stuff cuz I'm not like an overweight
woman. So, I don't I never watched
Frenemies. Um so, I don't know any of
this, but it's kind of crazy to me Ethan
had to lie to win against Trisha Paytas.
That's [__] crazy.
>> The only time Trisha even remotely
approaches suggesting sexual harassment
was when she complained that Ethan was
sexualizing her beauty products.
>> None of it felt right. Being sexualized,
skin care being sexualized, you know,
none of it felt right.
>> After Ethan watched the video,
>> Maybe if I was like a fat hog, I don't
know what's going on. Anyway,
>> Did she say I sexually harass her? No,
she didn't say that, but she said I was
making everything sexual. I was making
her beauty products sexual. I feel like
she really tried her app She She tried
to ruin my life, my reputation, my
business.
>> And this is what Trisha was referring
to.
>> This is your self-love bottle. This is a
>> What?
>> Look at you. You're like, oh, like like
a What was like a money shot? I was
saying she squirts this [__]
>> your self-love
>> Also kind of phallic.
>> What?
>> You say Trisha what's the secret? And
then you show like a phallic It looks
like a [__] Balls and [__]
>> What are you talking about?
>> Look, two balls and a [__] It's like a
giant phallus.
>> This is the products in the Oh.
>> Bro, it's literally a penis.
>> I'll come back to that.
>> in your makeup?
>> I have a makeup wipe I take my makeup
off.
>> in your makeup?
>> Huh?
What?
>> Is there semen in your makeup?
>> No.
>> I don't even care that Ethan did this. I
mean, yeah, that looks like dick and
balls. But, Ethan acted so disgusted at
the idea that he would do something like
that and said that Trisha must have been
trying to ruin his reputation. The
irresponsibility of Ethan's reaction is
likely what led to many H3 fans
believing that Trisha accused him of
actual sexual assault, and they might
still believe that to this day. You
might call what Ethan did here a false
false accusation.
>> He's lying.
>> But while Ethan did acknowledge that
Trisha didn't accuse him of sexual
harassment, would it really have been
that crazy if she had?
>> Well, a ton of the comments
>> That's hate. That's hate. Let's say
Let's say Ethan potentially sexually
harassing Trisha Paytas. Let's say it.
>> said things like uh talking about my
mom's breasts and asking if I was
breastfed because uh they heard in a
previous episode Ethan talking about my
mom's breasts in detail.
>> her mommy milkers
>> Yes, that's right. That Yeah, to quote
Ethan, I believe.
>> So, I was hoping you could help me.
>> I can help you. I'd love to help you,
actually. I've actually dreamed of
helping you. What happened your hand,
buddy? Jerking off too hard? Is that a
masturbation injury?
>> She has tried to uh penetrate him with a
strappy
>> Stop. Don't need to bring it up all the
time.
>> Well, not all the time. It's what, my
third time since I learned about it?
>> days.
>> There's this guy Brad the Bull who's
like railing his wife, but that's
neither here nor there.
>> Hassan's the type of dude who look
watches himself in the mirror when he
has sex.
>> That's funny.
>> Okay, that was weird when you said that.
>> Really?
>> Yeah.
>> I thought it was funny.
>> It Well, I'm sure that I
>> It It's like It made me uncomfortable. I
don't know. I don't like it.
>> It's just a lot of volume cuz when
you're eating [__] you need to make
sure that
>> Oh, you went to Italy for how long?
>> 4 weeks.
>> You went to Italy. You guys stayed in
touch. No strange Italian dick, I'm
assuming.
>> No.
>> Have you seen your dad naked? Does Ian
walk around naked? If you had privacy,
would you walk around naked? Butt ass
naked?
>> By the way, Anissa reached out. She
wants to meet at the Motel uh 6 tonight
at 11:00.
>> Excuse me?
>> Because I'm going to [__] him for her
cuz she's the [__]
>> You know, the first time that you made
the Anissa the [__]
>> There's a level where this is like, you
know, obviously the immediate thought is
I mean, it's on a podcast, it's like
they're joking around and all this [__]
But especially with like employees, and
to be honest with other content
creators, too. If you're going to be
making these like, you know, super
sexual comments, you probably know
they're okay with it first, you know?
And some of these the people don't seem
like 100% cool with that.
>> joke
>> Well, why did it hit really good?
>> Well, what happened? I feel like each
subsequent one we're getting further and
further.
>> What was wrong with the one that with
that? I thought that was
>> It just sounded weird, kind of creepy.
>> Okay, if you're going to constantly joke
around like that with people you know
personally, including your own
employees, you don't get to react like
this when you think one of them might be
accusing you of sexual harassment.
Anyway, that was just one of what might
have been many potential examples of
Ethan misrepresenting things during the
fallout with his former co-host. But
their breakup was a total [__] show, and
it's possible Trisha isn't the most
reliable person, either. So, maybe
you're willing to give Ethan some grace
with this one. Understandable.
But what about the defamation lawsuit
that was filed against Ethan by Ryan
Kavanaugh? In 2021, Ethan was sued by
Triller, which one of Kavanaugh's
companies had a controlling interest in.
The lawsuit was related to the H3
podcast streaming clips from a boxing
match between Jake Paul and Ben Askren,
which was a pay-per-view event that
Triller owned the exclusive rights to.
Now, Ethan did admit to pirating the
fight in DMs with Philip DeFranco,
saying that he didn't want to
financially support Jake Paul, who'd
been credibly accused of sexual assault.
But the lawsuit was specifically for
copyright, especially given that Ethan
had shown on screen an unlisted link to
a full upload of the fight. Ethan
objected strongly to this lawsuit,
essentially suggesting that it was
frivolous and he was being unfairly
singled out. One thing he noted was that
Triller had been dropping most of their
other lawsuits against actually
potentially illegal re-streaming sites.
>> So, literally, how can you ever defend
his current lawsuits when he was doing
this [__] man? How can you defend it?
It's so obviously hypocritical, and he
literally he mounted every argument in
his own defense that he possibly could.
Tried to appeal to everyone's principles
by like, "Come defend me. Come defend
Why is no one defending me?" When he
just he literally just pirated a fight
and rebroadcast parts of it when it was
a pay-per-view and showed the link. You
can't do that. It's It's a That is like
literally that is like, you know, he
tries to act like, "Oh, DeNims is going
to make Sony come down on everyone." No,
that's the sort of [__] that makes
companies come down on people, you
[__] idiot. That's the It's not
reacting to people's YouTube videos
where they're talking about a song.
That's not the sort of [__] that causes
a Sony lawsuit. The sort of [__] that
causes a Sony lawsuit is taking stuff
that you have to pay for, pirating it,
sharing the pirated link, reacting to
it. That's That's That's how you get
huge companies to do massive like we
did. Like we did.
>> But most of those sites, they didn't
have strong evidence against. Whereas
Ethan broadcast the fight and a link to
it on a recorded live stream. Triller
also made it known that they would be
taking an aggressive approach to suing
people who pirated or redistributed
their product. And Ethan wasn't the only
content creator they pursued to that
end. But his frustrations and public
statements about the case led to a
series of additional lawsuits between
him and Triller, which Ethan Klein chose
to respond to by beginning to disparage
Ryan Kavanaugh on the H3 podcast for
months on end. Ethan would go live and
vent his frustrations with Triller and
Kavanaugh dozens of times over the
course of the next several months, but
the attacking quickly
>> Kind of like what the Snark Sub did. Is
it
Is it kind of like what the Snark Sub
did though? Is it kind of like what
Maybe we'll find out. Maybe we'll find
out.
>> weird territory. Ethan became quite
fixated on Ryan's ex-wife, for instance,
and he'd routinely do bits on the show
about her and her new husband, including
detailed descriptions of their
hypothetical sexual activity.
>> Look how big the bull is though, man. He
probably plows the [__] out of her,
dude. Brad [__] rails her hard.
Imagine getting railed by that, dude.
You Your wife is getting railed by a
giant [__] Israeli dude with jacked,
huge Jewish [__] and your wife loves
it. You stand in the closet and and
listen as your dick is in a [__] cage.
>> And while we're here, I think it's worth
noting that Ryan separated from his
ex-wife in 2020, a year before the
lawsuit was even filed. So, she and her
new husband had absolutely nothing to do
with it. But, Ethan and his community
had no hesitation in involving her in
their smear campaign against her former
husband. And
>> And he will cry that if you identify
Teddy Fresh employees as plagiarizing
designs,
uh you're you're harassing you're
harassing his staff. If you criticize AB
and call him a dog as a dog, they'll say
you're harassing the crew. But, they can
just go after people's wives who they've
separated from a year before.
>> And when I say involved, I mean
directly. The incessant mentioning of
Kavanaugh's ex-wife led H3 fans to start
brigading her and her new husband's
Instagram page, where they left tons of
very weird and hypersexual comments.
>> I was probably getting 20 to 30,000
death threats. He started telling them
to go after my my ex-wife, who's my best
friend and mother of my child. She was
getting
death threats. They were they were just
I mean, it was to the point where I
couldn't ignore it anymore.
>> And again, these two were not involved
in the lawsuit in any way whatsoever.
But, not only that, Kavanaugh himself
claims to have had almost nothing to do
with it personally.
>> And it went after, I don't know, five or
six sites. I I kind of wasn't involved.
I just, you know, knew they were doing
it. And then one day, someone called me
and said, "You know this this guy's like
just trashing on you on his podcast."
I'm like, I've never heard of this guy.
Why would he be doing that?
And they're like, "They say you're suing
him." And I'm like,
"I've never heard of him. Why would I
sue him?" Needless to say, I kind of
ignored it. And then over the next
month, they're like, "This guy's done
like 30 podcasts." Like, and then it was
like 50.
>> Ethan and the H3 crew even went so far
as making an entire website dedicated to
comparing Kavanaugh to convicted rapist
Harvey Weinstein.
>> Our a website about Ryan Kavanaugh.
>> Does Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
Weinstein?
>> Oh, that's the one.
>> To date, Ryan Kavanaugh has been
mentioned on the H3 podcast in at least
156 different episodes, many of which
came after Ryan retaliated against them
by filing a defamation suit against
Ethan. That case specifically cited
comments that Ethan repeatedly made
about Ryan's business operating as a
Ponzi scheme, which Ethan sourced from a
2019 article from Variety. The issue
there is that Variety had amended this
article within 24 hours after it was
posted, including a full retraction from
the original person who called Ryan
>> There, it's so [__] crazy how bad he
did this Ryan Kavanaugh guy, man. So
much worse than Ethan can claim about
like any content creator that's pretty
much ever spoken about him. Even
Badempanada, I don't think did something
as brazen as taking something from an
article that had already been corrected
and fully retracted. Crazy.
>> Ryan's business a Ponzi scheme. Now, it
seems like this case was ultimately
settled outside of court, but Ethan was
forced to issue an on-stream apology
after the court rejected his motion to
dismiss the case, finding that he had
been aware of the retraction, but
repeatedly restated the false assertion
anyway over the following months.
>> You're a liar. You lie.
>> I skipped some of the crazier details
about this story, like how Ethan
supposedly paid editors to constantly
monitor Kavanaugh's Wikipedia page and
insert more negative information about
him.
>> I won this lawsuit against the guy who
propagated it and who's paying to have
all these editors do this. The appeal
will be held this summer and he'll have
to take it all down. We went to a
mediation and he agreed to even do it,
which is why I know he
I mean, I already knew he controlled it,
but he admitted it.
>> But either way, even if you think Trisha
is a crazy person or Ryan Kavanaugh's an
[__] Ethan has still shown that he's
willing to misrepresent claims, falsely
attribute things to others, and even
outright defame people that he doesn't
like. This kind of stuff is a favorite
pastime for Ethan. He likes to jump to
conclusions and just say [__] about
people, often with no evidence. He
implied or outright suggested that Dan
Clancy and Taylor Lorenz were pedophiles
for like no reason. He wrongly accused
the Wall Street Journal of doctoring
photos and then had to walk it back.
While he himself has routinely had
issues with sharing fake or doctored
social media posts and passing them off
as real, and he's shown a willingness to
contort and misrepresent events in his
life whenever it suits his purposes,
which is what he's doing now in his war
against Reddit, Twitch, and Hasan.
>> The harassment that me and Ela are
receiving
is just genuinely unfucking comparable.
Like nothing I've ever dealt with. And
to the point where I just I don't know
how it's so
>> Like nothing he's ever dealt with. Not
like nothing not like not like anything
he's ever done, you know? Not unlike
anything he's ever done. As we're as
we're clearly saying, he was doing the
same if not worse to Cavanal, to Trisha
Paytas. Just these are just his tactics.
If anything, they're more mild, frankly.
>> allowed on Reddit. Like an organized
harassment campaign spreading across
multiple subreddits targeting like one
specific two specific people. It's so
[__] up. And once again, to remind
everybody that Reddit has no problem
with this community that exists solely
to do the most insane, unhinged,
unacceptable harassment campaigns you
can possibly imagine. On the internet
today, people think they can say
anything they want about me. And by the
way, her posting this is continuing the
defamation and this whole like snark
narrative that they're trying to make
like mainstream. And by the way, they're
part of the harassment campaign that I
can't believe is so big. They're
misrepresenting everything I said.
They're mischaracterizing, like taking
things out of context, [__] like you
guys are part of that harassment
campaign, you scumbags.
>> Ever since the Left Arm's podcast ended,
Ethan has spent almost 2 years trying to
convince the online world that he is the
victim of a massive organized harassment
campaign, which is being spearheaded by
Hasan and his surrounding network of
evil harassers, or something like that.
This harassment narrative itself is
being pushed pretty effectively by
Ethan, and he's received quite a lot of
support from across the internet. So,
while he's been aggressively retaliating
against his enemies, like his use of the
legal system, to many it's
understandable or even justified. But is
Ethan's narrative accurate? To answer
that, let's go back to the beginning of
the Ethan and Hasan feud back in late
2023. You'll remember from earlier that
one of the first major sources of
tension between the two was Ethan being
upset at things that Hasan's chat was
saying about him.
>> that your your chat is calling me
racist? Do you make any attempt to to
>> I have not looked at my chat
>> moderate that
>> I have not looked at my chat at all.
>> The thing with this argument is, first
of all, I don't know what Ethan expected
Hasan to do about a chat that looked
like this. Like, look at this [__] But
more importantly, Ethan seems to not
understand that you are the only person
who is responsible for the things that
you say on the internet. It's nobody
else's job to protect you if audiences
and comment sections have a negative
reaction to the things that you're
saying. The backlash that Ethan's been
getting online from communities like
>> having a total meltdown at this point.
Anyone that disagrees with that is
totally [__] He was putting his
foot in his mouth a bunch. He sounded
like a totally [__] insane person.
You can be, you know, empathetic and be
like, "Oh, well, he's you know, he loves
Israel. He loves Israel, so he's really
upset."
But it doesn't change the fact that
obviously people who vehemently disagree
with that are going to have issues with
it.
>> Hasan's. It doesn't just unfairly come
from nowhere. It is a direct response to
controversial ideas that he and Ela have
expressed after the conflict in Gaza
started.
>> why people are saying that is because of
the conflations that you made, Ethan. I
can't stop people from viewing you a
certain way if you're going to make
these comparisons that they've heard
from actually racist people.
>> Now, to be fair to Ethan, he has
repeatedly expressed support for
Palestine and condemned the actions of
Israel during the war.
>> What is happening in Gaza is disgusting
and it needs to stop immediately.
>> But the Klaans have also often shown a
tendency to couple these general
condemnations of Israel with things like
flowery
>> He had you had you in the first stuff.
See, to be fair to Ethan, to be fair to
Ethan, he does he does say the right
thing sometimes. That's not the case.
It's not really the case.
>> praise about the country and how free it
is.
>> What I want to do is show you guys how I
see Israel. How beautiful, how
multicultural, how like free it feels
for people or just
>> Or highly incendiary statements about
people who were saying free Palestine
too closely to October 7th.
>> When you come out and say free Palestine
after they just lost everybody, that's
not what you should be saying right now.
>> And I'm free Palestine, too, right? It's
just the timing, I know what it is.
You're saying I support Hamas. I mean,
that's what you're That's what you're
saying. I'm just saying don't cheer for
terrorists. I don't think that that's a
crazy take. If you think it is, then
let's go invite the Iraqi terrorists who
are exacting revenge to come to your
city block and kill every [__] one
you love. If you think Hamas is dope,
just remember you deserve
>> So, he's saying if you're saying free
Palestine right now, you're saying you
love Hamas. Okay? If you're saying you
love Hamas, let's invite the Iraqi
terrorists to come and steal everything
your neighbor had. So, if you are saying
free Palestine, let's invite Iraqi
terrorists to come and steal it since
you love them so much. That was Ethan's
take around October 7th. And it's
apparently it's a totally It's a totally
[__] crazy read to say this guy's a
Zionist. You say this guy's a Zionist,
Reese, and he's about Israel or
maybe suggest that he he backs genocide
in a YouTube video. You're insane. Why
would you Why would you ever say
something like that? You're totally
crazy. You're a crazy woke leftist,
frankly, third worldist who wants uh uh
Muslims to to ravage your country or
whatever the [__] they say. How could
you possibly say something like How
could you possibly be so crazy when this
guy is having the biggest [__] you
know, Zog's bug out recorded online up
to that point.
>> deserve to be You're just saying don't
cheer for terrorists. I don't think that
that's a crazy take. If you think it is,
then let's go invite the Iraqi
terrorists who are exacting revenge to
come to your city block and kill every
[__] one you love. If you think Hamas
is dope, just remember you deserve to be
burned alive by terrorists and your
whole family murdered in front of you.
>> Ethan's also been criticized for
spreading misinformation about important
historical events regarding Palestinian
suffering or for uncritically accepting
negative stories about their combatants.
>> H3 promoted the beheaded babies myth
extensively.
>> Do you Do you want to go back again?
>> Invite the Iraqi terrorists who are
exacting revenge to come to your city
block and kill every [__] one you
love. If you think Hamas is dope, just
remember you deserve to be burned alive
by terrorists and your whole family
murdered in front of you.
>> So remember guys, he said saying free
Palestine in the wake of October 7th,
that's equivalent to loving Hamas.
That's that's in the same stream. That's
in the same stream. What does he say?
>> what it is. You're saying I support
Hamas. I mean, that's what you're That's
what you're saying. I'm just saying
don't cheer for terrorists. I don't
think that that's a crazy take. If you
think it is, then let's go invite the
Iraqi terrorists who are exacting
revenge to come to your city block and
kill every [__] one you love. If you
think Hamas is dope, just remember you
deserve to be
burned alive by terrorists
>> Guys, this is on a violent stream.
Listen to what he Listen to that. He
says, you deserve. It's not that point.
When he gets to that point, it's no
longer like some hypothetical. It's no
longer like if you think this is a take,
maybe this should happen to you. Like a
how would you like it type thing. Like
an almost a
uh
You know, if you care so much about
Metta Metta World, you do Rick Scott.
Almost like that. But it stops being
that, doesn't it? It's It becomes you
deserve to have your family burned and
killed. Dude.
>> If you think it is, then let's go invite
the Iraqi terrorists who are exacting
revenge to come to your city block and
kill every [__] one you love. If you
think Hamas is dope, just remember you
deserve to be
burned alive by terrorists and your
whole family murdered in front of you.
>> Ethan's also been criticized
>> Cuz he did cuz Ethan has such violent
speech, man. Ethan says such crazy
things. I can't believe it.
>> for spreading misinformation about
important historical events regarding
Palestinian suffering or for
uncritically accepting negative stories
about their combatants.
>> H3 promoted the beheaded babies myth
extensively, for example, and has not
retracted since.
>> While being overly skeptical or just
rejecting negative stories about Israel.
>> I mean, listen, that's a huge claim. 15
Palestinian women were raped.
>> I couldn't really find a lot of evidence
to back it up.
>> I understand why Ethan's brain would
operate this way, and it's not like
there's anything immoral about having a
bias. But obviously, at a certain point,
after Ethan makes enough comments like
this, to a lot of people, he's going to
start to sound like he's defending
Israel a little bit, like kind of
reflexively.
>> They could have held a ceasefire at any
point. They could have ended it after a
week.
>> Hamas could have ended the war anytime,
too.
>> How could have Hamas ended the war?
>> By leaving, by releasing the hostages.
>> Hamas offered all the hostages an
agreement for Israel not coming into
Gaza. To defend Israel's actions
>> That didn't happen, either.
>> Yes, it did.
>> This type of thing is why people think
that Ethan and Ela are running defense
for Israel, and there are dozens of
examples of this. There's Ela
essentially saluting IDF pilots on
Instagram after Israel's strike on Iran.
Or there's also her referring
>> Okay, and this video has been in the
works for a while. They say this is
about the nuclear strikes on Iran last
year, um, not about their most recent
strikes.
>> saluting IDF pilots on Instagram.
>> They were They were posting videos of
like They were like women throwing off
their their hijabs, throwing off their
headscarves. Like so [__] funny, man.
>> after Israel's strike on Iran. Or
there's also her referring to former
Israeli Minister of Defense Yoav Gallant
as a really good guy, a man who is
currently wanted by the International
Criminal Court for war crimes, including
directing attacks on civilians. Nobody
made her say that. Nobody made Ethan
defend it, but the client
>> No, you don't understand. He was a
moderating voice in the war cabinet
because he just said that the operation
Gaza had already achieved all its
military objectives, and there was no
use to us for us still being there even
though Ava quoted called Palestinians
human animals in separate quotes and
directed attacks on civilians.
>> I love it, man. I love it. That's one of
my favorite defenses. That's one of my
favorite Ela defenses.
>> And seem to want to endlessly make
comments on this very controversial
subject and expect to never be attacked
for the things that they're expressing.
They think that because they say the
words we support Palestine that the
people that criticize them must just
hate Jewish people.
>> He's watching the same clip over and
over retweeting like psychopathic
anti-semites. There's no other
explanation for these people being so
weirdly obsessed with her.
>> To a lot of people, Ethan saying
genocide is bad is probably not
adequate. Genocide being bad is
>> Yeah, she apologized. She didn't. She
didn't. She didn't. She never said sorry
in that entire video.
>> obvious. That's a default position. To
them, this situation would be kind of
like someone saying rape is bad and then
talking about how much they'd love Bill
Cosby.
>> After people have some of my barbecue
sauce, after a while when it kicks in,
they get all huggy-buggy.
>> Jesus. Anyway, you get what I'm trying
to say. The point is that Ethan and Ela
are the ones choosing to put this stuff
on the internet. Like during the height
of what many people consider to be a
genocide by Israel, Ela posts on
Instagram last February showing off her
new blue Star of David tattoo. You know,
like the one on the Israeli flag. Now
yes, blue is a traditional color in
Judaism, but a lot of that is because of
its appearance on the flag of Israel.
There are a lot of people that
understandably are not going to like an
apparent show of support for a country
that's been accused of using chemical
weapons near civilians or opening fire
on people waiting for aid. But here's
how Ethan responds to negative comments
on Ela's post about her tattoo.
>> obsessed with you guys when you only had
15k subs. Glad that's behind me. Enjoy
hell. This guy's for real. Joe Coople
Joe Coop. Look this guy up.
Enjoy hell. He said enjoy hell.
>> Yeah, yeah. No, I mean they they think
I'm actually the devil.
>> Here he is if anyone Let's see if I know
Can I identify him at all?
>> Joe
Rogan. You saw [__] stupid bro. I
think it's this guy.
I trust me, when I see an anti-Semite I
know I can spot him.
Spot him in from a crowd.
So I don't know if you guys all know
that but your friend Joe here actually
is a [__] giant racist piece of [__]
And like he likes to tell Jewish people
they're going to hell on Instagram on
his public profile. I don't know if any
of you guys know him but certainly
anyone who would employ him or probably
even his parents would be pretty
disappointed to see that although who
knows. Here's his mom. I'm not going to
click that for her. You know what you
know what [__] him.
>> So I'm pretty sure Ethan doesn't control
his camera so the crew have actually
switched off before he switches over to
looking at the mother's Instagram file.
>> Your mom. I wonder if she knows what
what you do on social media in your free
time. You love your mama. Good thing
she's not Jewish hey Gel. I love it.
>> And yeah, Ethan's producer cuts away
from the Instagram feed there so that
Ethan doesn't blast the guy's mom to his
thousands of viewers. This clip comes
across kind of deranged to me but it
gives you a little bit of a window into
how Ethan's mind works. To him people
can't simply be having a response to
controversial statements or things they
themselves have put out there. It must
be because of anti-Semitism or bigotry.
And ultimately I think the reason why
Ethan reacts this way is because in
reality he cannot stand being
criticized.
>> There's been a lot of criticism of me of
late. There's been a lot of people that
have said
lots of lots and lots of videos. I have
a natural aversion to criticisms
specifically which is something that
I've been learning about myself through
therapy which I've started recently.
>> Ethan cannot help himself from comment
sections, Reddits, tweets about him. He
obsesses over how he's being perceived
and he compulsively responds to almost
anybody that's critical of him. And he
has a long history of this temperament.
As a quick example, there was this call
on election night that Ethan had with
Philip DeFranco where Ethan for like
literally no reason awkwardly tries to
force into the conversation how people
on the internet just hate him because
he's Jewish.
>> Well I don't know if you knew this about
me Phil but
I'm Jewish. Yeah, it's pretty
controversial but
>> Yeah, I can go into detail. Do you want
to we can we I could go into all the
details.
>> Don't push it. Sounds like you want to
get into it. Sounds like you want to get
into it.
>> Thank you.
>> And then immediately after getting off
that call, Ethan goes out of his way to
pull up Philly's chat and whine about
things people are saying about him.
>> Okay, be good. Be good. Yeah.
>> Nothing gets me excited like seeing
Philip DeFranco's chat call me El Zinus
Nazi, free Palestine, Ethan you can
migrate to Israel.
>> And finally, when he gets criticized by
the group for killing the vibe of the
podcast, this is how he responds.
>> How the [__] did I kill the mood?
What the [__] did I do?
>> You killed the mood.
>> Why? How?
>> But with your calling Phil and BRINGING
UP ALL
>> [__] AWESOME.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS A FUN CALL.
>> YEAH, what the [__] what what's hap What
am I do What is this world we're living
in? What's happening right now? Tell me
how.
>> I told you
>> Tell me how.
>> I don't have I don't have a way to get
through to you then.
>> I There's no chance. That call was
awesome.
>> I I didn't I didn't feel awesome coming
off that call.
>> Why? I'm just telling you. Was that call
awesome?
>> Because it turned into you just
complaining about his chat, everybody
like they [__] hate you and they're
spamming it or whatever.
>> Ethan's obvious ruminating on criticism
shows up in a lot of places. He left
Twitter in favor of Instagram, probably
because stories don't have comment
sections.
>> Dude, he was on something here. It was
pretty crazy the way he called into
Philly days.
>> H3 also seems to often heavily filter or
disable comments on episodes that they
think might get some pushback. And I've
also recently found that the H3 podcast
commonly cuts out entire sections of
their live streams, even sometimes way
after the fact, seemingly in response to
criticism, which I guess they do have a
right to do, but I will say as someone
who's currently trying to criticize
them, it's pretty [__] irritating.
But all this is to say, Ethan isn't a
fan of being criticized at all. And when
he started facing a lot more negative
scrutiny after October 7th, it seems
like he wanted Hasan to exert sweeping
control over his entire audience's
perception of him. And despite how
unrealistic that is, Hasan still tried.
>> Ethan is not your enemy. You should not
yell at Ethan. Ethan is my friend. He's
an empathetic person. I will always
stand by Ethan's ability to empathize
and want to learn and want to change his
perspective. Change
>> It's so crazy how much [__] sweeping
Hassan did for this [__] bro. Legit,
that's the bigger criticism of Hassan,
yeah. Hassan swept for Ethan at the
start. Hassan was trying to hold on to
the friendship. Hassan swept for Ethan,
tried to say
Hassan is not this guy, he's not
Hassanist. He can lie and he can lie.
No, he hates you. He seen an opportunity
and he hates you.
>> your perspective on an issue that is
like near and dear to your [__] heart
is virtually impossible. I will forever
have respect for him for doing that on
his own. You need to as a community also
stop [__] ripping into Ethan
non-stop. But it was never quite enough
for Ethan. He genuinely hates you, bro.
I know.
I know he does.
I wish him well regardless.
>> And eventually Ethan declared war on all
things Hassan, which brought us to where
we are now. Now, what Ethan could do is
he could stop reflexively defending
Israel. He could stop commenting on the
issue altogether. Maybe he could reflect
on and internalize some of what people
are telling him. Or he could change
nothing and just accept that some people
on the internet are going to have a
problem with it. But of course, he
hasn't done any of these things. Ethan
has instead chosen to lie.
He's built this myth of a mass
harassment campaign against him and he's
using this lie to try to financially
harm Twitch, change Reddit policy, and
abuse the court system against the
people that he holds responsible for his
decline in popularity.
The three main things that Ethan's been
dishonest about are H3 Smark, the CPS
call, and the copyright lawsuits.
Let's start with Smark.
After the left of
>> So, literally, there's so much
foundation laying here with Ethan stuff.
We are literally We are nowhere close to
the Oreo, nowhere close to Tech Tone.
>> represented the growing rift between
Ethan and his son's communities, sparked
increased activity on the H3 snark
subreddit. For those of you that don't
know what snark means, here's a quick
overview. Snark communities are online
groups dedicated to sharing negative or
critical content about a figure that the
group is centered around. That's it.
They're basically just groups of people
who dislike an influencer or public
figure and they talk about them, laugh
about them, criticize them. That's all
it is. H3 has had their own snark
community since early in 2023, but as
Ethan's content became more political
and as the feud with his son began, it
gradually started growing in popularity.
Now, it should be noted that most of
these places, especially on Reddit, have
strict rules against crossing the line.
They typically moderate against posts
that encourage or facilitate harassment,
such as doxing, and the ones that don't
usually don't last very long on the
platform. You can always find psycho
people who engage in poor behavior in
literally any online community, even fan
ones, but this doesn't mean the
community itself is an issue. For this
reason, as a concept, snark seems mostly
harmless. But Ethan doesn't see it this
way, and even since before The Leftovers
ended, Ethan has taken massive
>> Kilos probably hasn't gone down in
viewership at all. It's still It's still
holding at 500. It's crazy. That's
awesome.
>> issue with his own snark community, and
he essentially considers them to be
headquarters of the harassment campaign
that he believes he's facing.
>> H3 snark, which is a subreddit dedicated
to not even like feedback, like just
blatant
horrific harassment and like defamation.
So, what exactly
>> is Ethan referring to when he talks
about this organized harassment and
defamation campaign? Honestly, it's a
little difficult to say. Ethan's been
historically pretty non-specific in his
complaints about snark, but he has on
occasion pointed out a few hard
examples, so let's look at some of
those. So, here's a post from a little
over a year ago speculating that Teddy
Fresh, the Klein's clothing brand,
potentially plagiarized the design of a
new release because in addition to the
visual similarities, the senior designer
for Teddy Fresh previously liked the
post from the designer they're alleged
to have stolen from. Here's Ethan
talking about this post on stream.
>> This is literally This is [__]
insane, man. This is insane.
>> Honestly, it's a little difficult to
say. Ethan's been historically pretty
non-specific in his complaints about
Snark, but he has on occasion pointed
out a few hard examples. So, let's look
at some of those. So, here's a post from
a little over a year ago speculating
that Teddy Fresh, the Klein's clothing
brand, potentially plagiarized the
design of a new release because in
addition to the visual similarities, the
senior designer for Teddy Fresh
previously liked the post from the
designer they're alleged to have stolen
from. Here's Ethan talking about this
post on stream.
>> On the Snark subreddit, the top post
right now is dedicated to identifying
and harassing non-public Teddy Fresh
employees. I We have no recourse. Like,
this is not okay what's happening. I
don't know how Reddit allows this. I
really don't. It It's [__] sickening.
>> Okay, so Ethan claims this post is
dedicated to identifying and harassing
non-public Teddy Fresh employees. But,
the problem is this person did have
senior designer at Teddy Fresh in their
public Instagram bio. Teddy Fresh also
routinely posts about their designers,
including their names, in their own
Instagram posts. And, Hila Klein has
posted this person on her own YouTube
>> Perfect chill.
>> Thank you for the photos 20. Really
appreciate it. Thank you.
>> channel, including naming them and
introducing them as a designer at Teddy
Fresh.
>> Sean.
>> How [__] crazy is this, man?
>> non-public Teddy Fresh employees. But,
the problem is this person did have
senior designer at Teddy Fresh in their
public Instagram bio. Teddy Fresh also
routinely posts about their designers,
including their names, in their own
Instagram posts. And, Hila Klein has
posted this person on her own YouTube
channel, including naming them and
introducing them as a designer at Teddy
Fresh.
>> I'm Sean, I'm resident senior designer
of Teddy Fresh.
>> The H3 crew seemed to be under the
impression that this post was a doxx by
the way because the document they
compiled on it was titled Snark doxx.
>> Oh, thanks for the raid, Sean.
>> on what I can see, this poster wasn't
trying to identify anybody.
[__] you guys are the ones that
identified them.
>> It's not a lie
if you believe it.
>> And furthermore, Ethan is shocked that
Reddit allows this post, calling it
targeted harassment. But how exactly is
an accusation of wrongdoing, by itself,
harassment? There's no call to action,
there's no threat, there's no invasion
of privacy. It's literally just a few
photos and evidence for their claim.
Surely Ethan doesn't
>> It's legit, it's just so [__] crazy.
It is clearly that Ethan was mad that
one of his designers, one of his wife's
designers, was getting caught for
plagiarism, was getting caught stealing
[__] Or that at least, you know,
there's the chance that was happening,
which happened a couple times, I think.
And he just starts accusing him of
doxxing to try and shut it down. And no
one [__] questions it. Nikki D isn't
out there questioning it. I think we
covered it before and spoke about this,
but you know, broadly people just don't
[__] talk about it.
>> consider it to be harassment to accuse
somebody of plagiarism, right? There's
this video, apparently by a former H3
Snark moderator, supposedly exposing the
harassment the community engages in. And
some of the examples they list are like
just listen.
>> The Snarkers would even post drawings of
crew members with the purpose of
everyone else in the live chat to make
fun of them. But the thing that stuck
out to me from the times I was looking
at the H3 Snark live chat that they
really, really, really hate Zach.
Whenever Zach was on screen, the H3
Snark chat would go crazy and comment
about how ugly Zach is.
>> Drawings? People calling Zach ugly? Oh
my god, we need to do something about
this. Oh, and by the way, Ethan fully
endorses this video.
>> An ex-Snarker made a video about the
Snark subreddit that I thought was
wonderful. This all took place on
Reddit's platform. They have a live chat
feature that every during
>> Like, dude, this is what they're crying
about. Wow, Zach did show up. Oh wait,
never mind, that's a plate of pancakes.
Huh?
>> Reminder to always be clipping.
>> Queen Elizabeth
>> has us fending off his enemies that
amount to Skyrim monster look-alikes,
and it's very humid and scary down in
these mines.
>> Thank you for the $3. Thank you.
>> Every show they would open up or they
would engage in targeted, relentless
harassment against all of us. I'm very
grateful to this person. People don't
understand the forces that I'm dealing
with of how [__] disgustingly evil
these people are.
>> So, look, if you scroll through the H3
snark page, you'll see posts that are
making fun of things Ethan has said,
sometimes clipping something from a
recent stream. Here's a post just
sharing something Hasan said about
Ethan. This subreddit is like 99% just
posts like this. So, I'm not saying
there's never been a post here that
could qualify as harassment, but if for
Ethan things like laughing at drawings
does qualify, it makes me seriously
question his judgment of the severity of
what's happening here. Moving on,
another part of Ethan's claim is that
this community is defaming him and his
business, and Ethan really doesn't like
defamation.
>> This is defamation, right? No,
defamation. Defamation. I'm literally
going to sue you for defamation.
>> Uh-oh.
>> But this part is even harder to evaluate
because Ethan is even less specific
about the defamation. He tends to just
generally kind of whine about defamation
and slander, and rarely, if ever,
provides any specific examples of it.
>> These are like three huge [__]
communities that are posting about me
and Ela every [__] day.
>> [__] relentless slander, straight-up
lies, defamation.
>> One of the only times I could find him
providing actual evidence was this
infamous Ramadan post, which contained a
lie that the H3H3 subreddit was removing
posts celebrating Ramadan. Ethan was
understandably pretty upset about this.
>> Is it even proven that it's a lie? I
don't even know that it's proven it's a
lie. I think it's assumed to be a lie
because they fought it so hard. I don't
know that it's even proven to be a lie.
But yeah, this is like the the big
shining example of snark lying about
them. It's posting that they deleted
posts about Ramadan when they didn't.
>> subreddit was removing posts celebrating
Ramadan. Ethan was understandably pretty
upset about this. But when you look into
what actually happened here, it seems
likely that this example of defamation
just doesn't really mean much of
anything. According to the moderators of
the subreddit, the post was originally
made by like a rogue mod on an alt
account. And once they found out that it
was false, they deleted the post,
demoted the user, and updated their
rules to have higher standards. So, one
user on a popular forum maliciously
spread misinformation, was caught, got
punished, and then the owners took steps
to try to prevent it from happening
again. So, this just isn't indicative of
any systemic or coordinated misconduct.
This is just called the internet.
>> Oh my god, dude. That Wesley Winter
[__] inbred right-wing [__]
apparently he just got the [__] [__]
kicked out of him by ethnic minorities
or something while he was making a home.
Oh my god.
>> Plus, it seems like this should be
hanging one up place like this to be
moderated. They have rules against
misinformation, and they do enforce
them. Like, if you go search through the
subreddit, you can find hundreds of
examples of the moderators telling the
subreddit not to contact sponsors, to
respect people's privacy, marking
certain posts as being satirical. All
things that point to them actually
trying to prevent harassment and
defamation. Like with any popular forum,
some stuff might occasionally slip
through the cracks, but this stuff would
be outliers. It's quite obviously not
the purpose of this community. So,
Ethan's claims that this place exists
solely to conduct an organized
harassment campaign against him are at
best flimsy, and at worst, kind of
[__] But, there's one more thing
Ethan has shown, and it's this
screenshot he shared from Discord of
supposedly a moderator of H3 Snark
sharing the address of the H3 and Teddy
Fresh studios. Now, if this is exactly
how Ethan describes it, it could be an
issue. But, this looks like a private
DM, not a public Discord server. There's
no information about who this was sent
to, whether this person is still a
moderator, whether
>> Is it when you're all engaging in like
litigation and stuff against each other,
simply showing me that there's a
discussion of addresses isn't enough,
you know? Like, a lot of the time that's
enough for like doxing claims. When
you're all engaging in litigation
against each other, it's it's, you know,
there are reasons your address might be
getting passed around. There are reasons
why the moderators might be discussing
the address.
>> server. There's no information about who
was sent to, whether this person is
still a moderator, whether they even
ever were a moderator, or whether any of
the other mods knew about it. So, I kind
of just don't really know what I'm
looking at here. Without more context,
this just isn't evidence of organized,
coordinated harassment. This could be
nothing more than just one person doing
something wrong, which again can happen
in any large online community. So, look,
my perception of what's happened here is
that Ethan conflates harassment with
unwanted negative scrutiny, and he might
even conflate slander with things with.
99.9% of the users here are just
talking, making jokes, criticizing him,
voicing their opinions. Some of them may
say things that are untrue or even
cruel, but dude, that's what the
internet is. H3 has millions of
subscribers. At a certain point, you
can't control what everyone says or
thinks about you. So, as far as I can
tell, Ethan just isn't the victim of
anything unique here, but obviously, he
disagrees, and his response to these
insults, to criticism, and to this one
lie that was ultimately removed.
>> I get why this is in the Hassan Bad
video. Well, because the Snark narrative
is tied in with the Hassan Bad
narrative. It's all, you know, it's all
sprouted from the Ethan victimization.
>> declaring all-out war on Reddit and H3
Snark.
>> And it's just [__] disgusting. Like,
Reddit, you are disgusting. [__]
shame on you. The CEO, the officers,
everybody who's in this company is 100%
liable for everything that's happening
on all these Snark subreddits.
>> He started by going to Reddit and
complaining about Snark numerous times,
demanding that they take action against
the subreddit.
>> And I've tried to notify Reddit, and
they just don't [__] care.
>> We reported it, and we were trying to
contact someone at Reddit.
>> I've gone through every avenue possible
with Reddit. If this doesn't get taken
care of, then I'm going to have to start
holding Reddit accountable.
>> Which led to quite a lot of whining from
Ethan when they chose not to do
anything.
>> The whole Snark phenomenon is so
pathetic that Reddit allows this [__] to
continue. This is another reason why I
just cannot [__] believe that Reddit
doesn't react. It's so [__] up that
Reddit allows this and doesn't do
anything.
>> But Ethan did eventually hear back from
Reddit, although he wasn't very pleased
with what they had to say.
>> We got We got a hold of someone at
Reddit and we told them about all the
snark stuff. It was a comms person and
they got back to us and they said,
"Well, you guys are harassing people
also. You're harassing people and
they're harassing people, so I don't see
the difference between your community
and their community."
>> And while it would be really funny if
Reddit actually said that to him, I
highly doubt that that's what Ethan was
told. I imagine he was told something
more like, "This community is totally
fine. They're not doing anything
different than your own is." But this is
where things started getting a little
weird. Ethan didn't just disagree with
Reddit's decisions. He started claiming
that Reddit was conspiring against him
to protect
>> Yeah, and he started spazzing out
talking about how oh, the Reddit offices
are just down the road in San Francisco
from the Twitch offices. I bet they'll
meet for coffee and talk about how they
hate me for being for being a Jew.
>> Snark.
>> I believe that Reddit is colluding with
the moderators of this snark community
and actively protecting it.
>> And to his credit, I'm sure that Ethan
really was on the verge of cracking this
thing wide open.
>> Twitch has been ideologically captured
and the people in that company are using
their terms of service selectively as a
form of activism. And I feel that I'm
getting the same treatment now from
Reddit. Did you know that these two
companies in San Francisco are their
headquarters are blocks away from each
other? It's just interesting. It It's
just interesting because it shows
there's some culture happening in this
>> Asking questions.
>> I think that these people are all very
similar-minded. I think that's what it
this is telling me.
>> Right. But somehow this airtight
narrative didn't gain quite as much
traction as Ethan would like. So he
started being somewhat openly dishonest
about it. For instance, when Adam
McIntyre's snark community got taken
down by Reddit, allegedly due to
behaviors similar to the h3 snark page,
Ethan took it as proof that Reddit is
conspiring against him. But he prefers
to just disregard the known fact that
Adam's page didn't get removed due to
any alleged behaviors, but rather
because it was completely unmoderated,
whereas H3 Snark has always had active
moderators. Ethan is aware of this, by
the way. He just chooses to believe
something else.
>> It's hard for him to be honest. He lies
a lot.
He does.
>> In fact, there are often pretty decent
explanations for why things on Reddit
haven't gone Ethan's way, but rather
than opening his eyes, everything only
leads him to further believe that Reddit
leadership must be snarkers themselves.
That's right, it's a big Reddit
conspiracy to harass Ethan Klein. That
That is literally what he believes.
>> I know that it's likely that one of the
admins who's being paid by Reddit is
participating and protecting it.
>> Ethan also started claiming that the
coordination and organized harassment
actually just happens in Discord
servers, which is why you won't find it
on the subreddit itself.
>> These [__] freaks that are in a
Discord sharing on all these things.
These people can sign up without any
info on their account. Most of their
activity's happening on Discord.
>> And it's kind of weird that he'd go that
route anyway, because somehow Reddit is
complicit in something truly horrific
here, but simultaneously none of it is
actually happening on Reddit. It's all
happening somewhere else. But despite
not having very much evidence, Ethan
remained incredibly determined to push
this harassment narrative. So
determined, in fact, that he made the
very classy decision to appropriate a
woman's suicide to further his agenda
against Snark. Michaela Reigns, also
known as SaveAFox, took her own life
back in June of last year. And Ethan,
within 24 hours of it being announced,
ran to Instagram to claim that Snark was
responsible. But
>> Well, it's not the first time he's done
this, either. Not the first time he's
done this, either. People with uh very
long memories, people with with
incredibly long memories, with very
good, very long memories, will remember
when Ethan was fighting with Keemstar.
He blamed Keemstar for Etika's suicide.
Now, there was much better uh
There was a much better argument for
that one, frankly, than there is in this
case. And in the case of Etika, Nick
DiOrio waxed [__] poetic in video
after video about how evil Ethan was for
doing it and how that's one of the evil
things Ethan's done that people forget
about and all this [__] Yeah, when this
happened, all he could muster was a
yeah, I disagree with Ethan in passing.
That's all he could muster.
>> Michaela's husband didn't cite her snark
community as contributing to her
suicide. He rather said that the
criticism Michaela faced was often from
people she knew or people from other
animal sanctuaries. Michaela's snark
page was pretty inactive with only 19
total posts in its lifetime. She also,
according to her husband, had a long
history of being in and out of therapy
with depression and various other mental
ailments. Now, I'm not saying it's
impossible that Michaela's snark page
contributed to her distress, but this
was obviously a deeply troubled person
and Ethan parading around her body for
his own narrative purposes and chalking
it all up to snark when he can't even
know that to be true is kind of a
disgusting thing to do. But, despite
these lies and conspiracy theories and
his appeals
>> go down even go on NicktheOrion's stream
and was like, yeah, I knew that [__]
wasn't true, but I didn't say anything
about it cuz [__] him.
>> to Reddit, Ethan was unsuccessful in
getting H3 snark removed. This is not
normal. This is [__] insane, unhinged
behavior that is being explicitly
sanctioned by Reddit continually. It's
nauseating. It's so, so, so [__] up.
So, he decided to escalate his tactics.
Ethan hired an attorney to begin issuing
copyright strikes against clips of the
H3 podcast that were getting posted on
their snark page. It's unknown exactly
how many strikes were issued, but they
went after quite a few, including some
clips as short as 20 seconds long. Ethan
has given various explanations for why
>> So, are we following this, guys? So, we
got I've noticed a lot of discussion
about false DMCA strikes recently,
right? A- Any- Anyone else seen
discussion of false DMCA strikes
recently? False DMCA strikes over
someone using a trivial amount of
someone else's content. As I understand,
there was a whole EFAP episode about
this recently, about false DMCA strikes
over a trivial amount of content.
I don't I don't know about you guys. I I
seem to I seem to remember that
recently. Just an interesting thing
about it, isn't it? Just an interesting
thing about.
>> So [__] up.
>> No one can claim that oh, that was years
ago or oh, those aren't my principles or
any stupid [__] like that. No one can
pretend that any bigger content creators
aren't being totally hypocritical. You
know, not literally nobody can even do
that. And if they do, they're clearly
being dishonest. They're very clearly
being dishonest.
>> So, he decided to escalate his tactics.
Ethan hired an attorney to begin issuing
copyright strikes against clips of the
H3 podcast that were getting posted on
their snark page. It's unknown exactly
how many strikes were issued, but they
went after quite a few, including some
clips as short as 20 seconds long. Ethan
has given various explanations for why
he was trying to get these posts
removed.
>> Me and my lawyer were extremely
conservative about which posts
qualified. The ones that I posted that I
DMCA'd on that were egregious.
>> At different times, he's claimed he was
only targeting members-only content or
posts that openly stated they were
trying to steal views, but neither these
turned out to be true. Clips that didn't
fit either of those parameters were
getting struck also. Eventually, some of
these snarkers were added to Ethan's
current lawsuits against Hasan's
Orbiters, which we'll come back to
later. But in these filings, we received
expanded explanations for some of the
DMCA takedown requests. And all of a
sudden, the justifications included
things such as posts that didn't have
enough comments on them. Not a great
reason. These filings also claim that H3
was very purposeful with what they chose
to strike, listing just seven examples
with detailed explanations for each
takedown. And in response to the idea
that he was trying to silence his
critics, Ethan would repeat this claim
on stream, asserting that he had only
struck a handful of clips from the
subreddit.
>> And your dumb [__] ass at the time was
saying I was silencing people, which
makes no [__] sense because there's
like a thousand posts up there and we
DMCA'd like five of them. But what
they're referring to is just a DMCA, one
of their posts of like the hundreds, if
not thousands, got DMCA'd. And so, the
story is that I'm trying to silence free
speech because one post of a thousand
got DMCA'd. Like I said, there's
hundreds of posts we removed maybe five
at most. But months
>> So the the obvious Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
So I don't give a rat's into a hit. But
the obvious goal of this, the reason why
they did these multiple copyright
strikes, is because they had found out
that's how Trisha got her snark Reddit
sub that snark sub Reddit shut down.
They showed Trisha snarks over it for
years. They loved it. Ethan loved it. We
showed it on stream all the time. They
showed it for years, and then Trisha got
it taken down by using DM repeated DMCA
strikes. So they thought they could do
the same. They thought they could do the
same. I wonder if Ethan in the other in
the other situations has taken tips from
other dishonest actors uh copyright
abuse. I wonder if he's taken tips from
the assets malicious use of copyright.
If he's taken tips from anyone else at
any point in in any of these lawsuits or
strikes. Maybe someone else who likes
registering stuff with uh the the
Library of Congress perhaps. Someone who
saw benefit in registering their content
with the Library of Congress shortly
before Ethan did his, maybe.
>> It only struck a handful of clips from
the subreddit.
>> And your dumb [__] ass at the time was
saying I was silencing people, which
makes no [__] sense because there's
like a thousand posts up there, and we
DMCA'd like five of them.
>> But what they're referring to is just a
DMCA. One of their posts of like the
hundreds if not thousands got DMCA'd,
and so the story is that I'm trying to
silence free speech because one post of
a thousand got DMCA'd. Like I said,
there's hundreds of posts we removed
maybe five at most.
>> But months earlier, when complaining
about Reddit's inaction against snark,
Ethan had previously claimed to have
successfully filed dozens of copyright
strikes against them. We've performed
dozens of copyright strikes on the snark
subreddit. We have removed dozens of
posts. So, is Ethan possibly lying to
downplay how many claims were being
filed? If he is, it might be because
what Ethan was actually trying to do was
get the subreddit banned as a result of
excessive DMCA notices, something that
he had seen work with other Snark
subreddits before.
>> She told me that she was aware that
there's Snark pages that will talk about
me and that talk about her or whatever.
And she was like, "I'm going to give you
this number of someone who can take down
your Snarks." These people will go
around and they will copyright strike
things on subreddits to get them all
these violations that then they get
removed. I'm pretty sure as well that's
how, you know, Trisha Paytas
>> Look at the [__] cogs turning, bro.
>> to get them all these violations that
then they get removed. I'm pretty sure
as well that's how, you know, Trisha
Paytas got the Trisha Land Reddit taken
down. But
>> But obviously that plan didn't work. So,
he started making public threats of
legal action against members of H3
Snark. And I wanted to briefly point out
the very funny way that he talks when
he's addressing Snark. He really thinks
he's that guy.
>> I will look for you.
I will find you.
>> Over Reddit, bro. Over Reddit.
>> I will sue you.
>> That Reddit mod.
>> He's already been granted a subpoena to
obtain the personal information of
prominent H3 Snark members, which he
claims is just for legitimate copyright
purposes.
>> And he's threatening to dox them.
>> It's not a dox, you dumb [__]
>> You know, Kayla was actually [__]
sweating trying to finish this little
Reddit in the last week.
>> Got a subpoena. Now, what happens to
that information? I don't know.
>> I literally just want to hold them
accountable for copyright infringement.
Court filings are all public.
>> So, if like their private information
shows up there, I literally can't help
it.
>> But if you're not trying to dox them,
then why say things like this? I mean,
he's just openly expressing here that
his goal is, at least partially, to
expose the identities of these Snarkers.
>> Like anyone that participated in that
sub should be humiliated, embarrassed,
and exposed. If I was one of these
people and had something to lose, who
had, let's say, a good job or was part
of a an elite university, something like
that, they would certainly not want
people to know what they've been up to.
They all have quite a lot to lose and I
will be the one that makes them lose
those things.
>> That is pretty explicit. I mean, just
look at one of the letters from Ethan's
attorney. Give us the identity of Snark
moderators or all of your personal info
will be made public. And this letter was
regarding a clip posted on H3 Snark that
was 90 seconds long. It seems obvious
that his primary motivation is not
really protecting his property.
But you know how we can be sure? Ethan
previously, not even that long ago, had
opened up the H3 IP to everybody and he
even gave his blessing to people
profiting off of his channel.
>> I am opening our IP to the world. If you
want to cut up clips from the podcast,
from our members live, from anything
with me in it, go for it, man. Monetize
it. I will not claim, I will not remove,
I will not do anything. I mean, to be
fair
>> Right guys,
so what when is this? January 25th,
2023. So that is not even that long ago,
really, is it? Just think, so what when
would it have been? It's It's 2023 is
October 7th, right? It's October 7th,
2023. He falls out with his son over the
course of that year into 2024. Then the
next year is like full-blown hate into
2025 and now early 2025 is content nuke.
So it's legit not even that [__] long
ago. It's like think about the timeline
there. It is not that long ago at all. I
I haven't people say that he took this
back. I haven't seen that. I haven't
seen that. People say that he only took
back for member stuff. I haven't even
seen that, but yeah, he did literally go
out there and say, "Clip my stuff. I
don't care."
>> Something like that.
>> embarrassed and exposed. If I was one of
these people and had something to lose,
who had, let's say, a good job or was
part of a elite university, something
like that, they would certainly not want
people to know what they've been up to.
They all have quite a lot to lose and I
will be the the
that makes them lose those things.
>> That is pretty explicit. I mean, just
look at one of the letters from Ethan's
attorney. Give us the identity of Snark
moderators or all of your personal info
will be made public. And this letter was
regarding a clip posted on H3 Snark that
was 90 seconds long. It seems obvious
that his primary motivation is not
really protecting his property.
But you know how we can be sure? Ethan
previously, not even that long ago, had
opened up the H3 IP to everybody and he
even gave his blessing to people
profiting off of his channel.
>> I am opening our IP to the world. If you
want to cut up clips from the podcast,
from our members live,
from anything with me in it, go for it,
man. Monetize it. I will not claim. I
will not remove.
>> Well, well, good thing he wasn't just
striking members content, isn't it? Good
thing he wasn't just striking members
content. He was striking people for
taking like 90-second clips. If it's
publicly available, free episodes, and
Nick DiAurio was just totally [__]
ignored it. He's totally It's been
publicly available, publicly known that
he's been doing this. Nick DiAurio has
been notified that he's doing it.
There's no segment on it. There's no
Ottly Noah e fap episode on it. There's
no nothing. There's no nothing.
>> I'm not doing anything. I mean, to be
fair, it's It's basically been my
policy. I don't claim or remove anything
really at all.
>> But now you're making it explicit.
>> Yeah. He was openly encouraging people
to monetize his property, even on
YouTube.
>> We opened our IP and there are starting
to be channels who are uploading
content.
>> And I started noticing
>> and and they're getting views and I'm
very happy.
>> But Redditors who don't profit off of
him at all, he has a massive problem
with his content being shared there. And
the only difference between these two
situations, one supports H3, the other
criticizes him. You can't blanket open
up your IP and then claim infringement
when you just don't like who's sharing
it. Either it's protected or it's not.
So, when it comes to H3 Snark, Ethan
seems to have abused DMCA as a guise to
try to silence his critics. That's it.
This whole snark controversy is really
interesting because when you zoom out,
it kind of gives you a lot of
perspective on Ethan's character. Like
how he stands staunchly against
involving people's families in online
drama.
>> that's super [__] and twisted about it
is how they go after people's families.
>> Except when he does it. Or how he hates
defamation and considers it harassment.
>> One of them fabricated a post. That's
defamation.
>> Except when he does it. Or how he thinks
snark is evil and should be wiped from
the internet. I'm against snark
subreddits. I stand opposed to all snark
subreddits. Wow. Except when he uses it.
Yeah, this is Ethan's web browser back
during his fallout with Trisha Paytas.
And you'll notice Ethan is a frequent
visitor of Trishyland, Trisha's snark
subreddit. Ethan and the H3 crew are
known to have been supporters and
regular visitors of various Trisha snark
pages, including multiple named after
their former podcast Frenemies. The H3
podcast was actually remarkably public
about being appreciative of snark back
when the target was somebody that they
didn't like.
>> Frenemies 2. Oh, you have to request to
join. Well, I got to request access now.
Love said he secured Frenemies 12, so
we're safe.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Wait, Frenemies 12 is us?
>> Yeah, we got it.
>> Go to Frenemies 12 people since
Frenemies 2 is closed.
>> Frenemies 2 is like home base. You know
what I mean?
>> Why have they done this?
>> The irony is that Ethan doesn't actually
have a problem with snark. In fact, when
his own fans engage in the same
behaviors that he accuses snark of,
he'll just pretend that it isn't
happening.
>> numbers game, okay? Some people
obviously from our audience are going to
be uh take it too far and be
inappropriate and say horrible things.
This is not my fan base. The them even
trying to make it about our fan base is
disingenuous.
>> These are all the same These are all the
messages about Ryan Kavanaugh's ex-wife.
>> Slightly old data, but one of the most
popular subreddits among people who also
post in H3 subreddit is a makeup snark
page. And there's nothing wrong with
that because the thing is, Ethan is a
controversial figure with millions of
followers. He's been involved in
countless dramas and public feuds with
others, and at that scale, criticism is
inevitable. Some of it is going to be
harsh. Some people might cross lines,
but that doesn't mean there's a massive
organized campaign against you. It just
means you're notable and there's a lot
of eyeballs on you. And I don't know how
to protect someone like Ethan from every
isolated incident of harassment on the
internet, but I know that the answer is
not silencing all of your critics.
Now, some of you might be thinking, "But
Keemstar, didn't these people send CPS
and schools to his house?" I don't blame
Ethan for taking matters into his own
hands. Well, let's see. In November of
2024, Ethan began threatening Reddit
with legal action if he couldn't get H3
Snark banned from the website. In
December, it was discovered that he had
been weaponizing DMCA against them. In
January, he finalized his plan to
ultimately sue them for
>> is a So, any rat [__] defense that any
fat [__] loser might try and deploy
here, right? "CPS CPS schools CPS
schools." This was before that, you
[__] Not only was it before that, you
knew about it before that. You knew
about it before that, and you swept
anyway.
>> copyright infringement. Then in
February, he began making vague threats
of doxxing and exposing the identities
of the Snark moderators. And the CPS and
schools incidents didn't happen until
March.
On March 7th of 2025, the H3 podcast
went live where Ethan and Ela would
discuss a child protective services
visit to their house that morning after
an anonymous call that was placed a few
days prior. The call was in response to
a story Ethan told on this episode a few
weeks earlier about his family having
possibly contracted Giardia. After
announcing what happened, Ethan followed
up with a video on his main channel on
March 10th, further discussing the CPS
call, as well as angrily berating H3
Snark, Hasan, Bad Empanada, really
anybody he could even remotely blame for
the incident. He especially took issue
with Denims, who he accused of
encouraging her community to call CPS.
The visit itself rightfully didn't
translate to any long-term consequences
for the Klein household, although Ethan
maintains that this was a malicious and
fraudulent attack on his family and that
the call had no merit. He also claims
that the caller impersonated somebody
close to the Klein family to bolster the
call's credibility. Like when he first
showed up, he's like, "It's somebody
that you know who made the report." And
I'm like, "No, okay." You could easily
impersonate
>> The CPS incident escalated Ethan's sense
of victimhood in a pretty massive way
and he started lashing out at anyone he
considered anywhere even close to
responsible. One such person was Ian
Joma, also known as iDubbbz. Ian is a
former well-respected comedy creator
turned not so well-respected failed
event coordinator. He and Ethan used to
occasionally collaborate on each other's
channels and always appeared to maintain
a positive relationship. But, Ian and
his wife Anisa over time also developed
friendships with Hassan, Denims, and
other similar creators. Because of these
conflicting friendships, Ian largely
avoided commenting on any of the Ethan
and Hassan drama to this point,
obviously preferring to stay out of it
and just do his pretty boring podcast
with his wife. But, after the CPS visit,
Ian and Anisa staying out of things was
no longer an option for Ethan. He
accused them of being cowards for not
speaking up to defend him the attacks
that were coming from people they're
associated with. The couple reiterated
on their podcast on March 11th that they
wanted to stay out of the conflict,
adding that they don't condone or
endorse any type of harassment that
Ethan received. We don't condone
harassment
of any kind. We don't condone harassment
of any kind.
>> Of any kind.
>> But, Ethan's attacks on them continued,
which led to iDubbbz releasing a pair of
his famed content cop videos in April
with Ethan as the subject. These videos
didn't get received very well, but I
actually think there's a few good points
in here, which will come back to in a
second. For now, the important thing to
remember is that the CPS call has become
sort of the cornerstone of the victim
narrative that Ethan is selling. Anyone
who criticizes Ethan's behavior, who
questions his motivations, who requests
more evidence for his claims, all he or
any H3 fans have to say to them is,
"They tried to take his kids away."
>> that's why they're the current villains.
Yes.
>> reiterated on their podcast on March
11th that they wanted to stay out of the
conflict, adding that they don't condone
or endorse any type of harassment that
Ethan received.
>> condone harassment
>> Mhm.
>> We don't condone harassment of any kind.
>> And
of any kind.
>> Mhm.
>> But Ethan's attacks on them continued,
which led to iDubbz releasing a pair of
his famed
>> So, Ethan was going crazy over those
clips, over that [__] That was it. That
was all. Nick was going crazy over that,
too. Nick thinks that's like a terrible
take. They were all going [__] crazy
over these clips. Obviously, they don't
actually believe it's crazy. They're
[__] lying because they just know
that Ian and Anisa are easy targets and
they can basically say whatever they
want about them and no one's ever going
to check them. They don't even think
that's crazy at all. They're just lying
because they're they're motivated to.
But yeah, that is why Ian and Anisa are
so hated by H3 and in in the H3 story is
because of those clips, because of that
clip.
>> content cop videos in April.
>> can cope and say it's because of the
content cops, but they were actually the
content cops barely said anything
controversial. So, they were just gay
videos. They were gay and ineffectual
videos. That was the biggest issue with
them. People want to go, "Oh, but they
did didn't mention CPS. They didn't
mention CPS." Well, CPS isn't relevant
to any of the [__] points being made.
It's like it's just an excuse because
they're totally melting down in one clip
and the excuse is, "Oh, CPS showed up
that day." Sorry, just because something
bad happens to you doesn't mean you get
to write away all responsibility for you
totally spurging out on a live stream
when you're a massive content creator.
Take a day off. Take a day off. It's
that [__] simple.
>> With Ethan as the subject, these videos
didn't get received very well, but I
actually think there's a few good points
in here, which we'll come back to in a
second. For now, the important thing to
remember is that the CPS call has become
sort of the cornerstone of the victim
narrative that Ethan is selling. Anyone
who criticizes Ethan's behavior, who
questions his motivations, who requests
more evidence for his claims, all he or
any H3 fans have to say to them is,
"They tried to take his kids away." and
the conversation gets shut down. But the
problem with the way that people have
framed this whole CPS thing is that it's
essentially given Ethan this free pass
to to say or do whatever he wants in
response, no matter how dishonest it is.
Let's get a sense of how CPS got called
on the client household. Here's the clip
that got shared around.
>> Olive has Giardia, which is a
it's a bacterial infection in the
intestines that makes you have diarrhea.
Olive has this. Yeah, she came to us
with it.
>> Okay.
>> She had diarrhea. So, she has Giardia,
so we have her on an antibiotic, but we
had to wait until Monday, which is
today. We just got it today. Sunny's
crawling around. He's putting everything
in his mouth. He's at that age. He has
Giardia.
>> Oh, [__]
>> And now Eli has Giardia.
>> For real?
>> I And now I think this morning I had
diarrhea.
>> god.
>> Jesus. What can I do to not get it from
you?
>> Yeah, I'm trying to
>> Cuz I'm not trying to get it.
>> No, it's the AC maybe.
>> It takes extremely ridiculous to get.
It's you have to ingest my poop.
>> Okay, so Ethan says in this clip that
his dog has Giardia, that his infant son
has Giardia, and that his wife has
Giardia. He then immediately says that
it's difficult to contract, and in order
to get sick, you would have to ingest
his [__] So, I mean the idea that Ethan
could have painted a picture for
somebody here of a baby crawling around
putting dog [__] in its mouth. It's
really not like the craziest thing in
the world. Like it does kind of sound
like that.
>> Olive has Giardia. She had diarrhea.
Sunny's crawling around. He's putting
everything in his mouth. It's extremely
ridiculous to get. It's you have to
ingest my poop.
>> His whole room was just
>> wallowing in the foulest diarrhea smell.
>> Dude.
>> And all the meanwhile he is covered in
low viscosity diarrhea. You guys you
guys will not be getting Giardia. It's
not like that.
>> So, yeah, Ethan told this story about
parasites and dogs and babies being
covered in [__] and his whole house
smelling like flowing frothy diarrhea.
And yeah, it's just disgusting. So, if
you heard that story and took it at face
value, you could understandably have
come away from it with a little bit of
concern. So, obviously somebody called
CPS expressing concern about these
sanitary conditions of the Klein
household.
>> There's And there's no other clips about
you think that either. Cuz Ethan Klein
Ethan Klein's really clean. And I doubt
he'd stake his whole career on defending
the cleanliness of Ethan Klein's home.
>> go any further, the obvious question is
was the CPS call malicious harassment or
genuine concern? And the answer to that
question is we don't know. I don't know,
you don't know, and Ethan doesn't know.
It could have been malicious, or it
could have been someone being reckless
or overzealous. But it also could have
been someone who heard the story and
genuinely believed the kids were in an
unsanitary or unhealthy environment. And
the thing is that ultimately it doesn't
actually matter whether the report was
made in good or bad faith. Even if the
Kleins are the victims of harassment
here, they're still responsible for how
they respond to it. And Ethan, despite
having no idea who placed the call or
what their intentions were, has accepted
no responsibility for himself, lied
about what happened, and dishonestly
exploited the entire situation.
One of the better points from Ian's
Content Cop videos is that Ethan tends
to abdicate any responsibility he has in
protecting himself online, and he
instead expects the world to protect
him.
>> Now, what Ethan does, instead of taking
any responsibility for sharing
>> Oh, apparently um the the video is
finished now, so there's a high quality
if you go to the actual video. Sorry
about that.
Let's go full quality. Where's the
iDubbbz bit?
>> is that Ethan tends to abdicate any
responsibility he has in protecting
himself online, and he instead expects
the world to protect him.
>> Now, what Ethan does, instead of taking
any responsibility for sharing too much
on his live stream, is that he decides
to attack specific creators like Denims
and say she was the source of the CPS
call.
>> Part of The thing is you can probably
get it from just not washing your hands.
Yes. Yes, you can. Yes. However, Ethan
When Ethan talks about it, he says you
would have to eat my [__] If you know
about giardia, you would know that
that's not that's not necessarily true.
It will ingest ingest, he said. You'd
have to ingest. So, it's like yes, if
you had additional information, you can
know that's not necessarily true, but
the way Ethan says it, it it either
could be that someone takes it as that
is the case that you do have to eat [__]
together, or they take that as Ethan
essentially relaying his experience,
that his understanding of it is that you
have to eat [__] together. Why would he
think that, right? Uh but obviously,
it's it's not the case. It's not the
case that you have to eat [__] to get
Giardia. But the point is that you
cannot just from the clip so say that
oh, anyone that's concerned about this,
anyone that goes far as thinking that
these kids are in a negligent home is
being dishonest and malicious. No,
that's not necessarily the case.
>> My criticisms of Ethan initially was the
openness. I think it's
a problem that you were that open,
Ethan.
>> And that's just true. Everyone kind of
understands that the more about yourself
that you put out there, the more you're
exposing to the many insane people that
exist on the internet. Ethan seems to
understand this. He tries to limit
sharing photos of his kids online
specifically for that reason.
>> I've literally given Ethan Klein credit
for not showing photos of his kids. I
think it is actually very cool of him to
try his best to not have his kids in
photos, in videos.
>> But when it comes to the CPS visit,
Ethan has spent the months since it
happened lashing out at Reddit, other
creators, anybody who he can get away
with trying to hold responsible. And he
has not for 1 second stopped and
examined how he might have been
responsible. Never has he said, "Man, I
told that story in kind of a stupid way.
No, maybe I shouldn't talk about my
kids' medical conditions in front of
thousands of people." Nothing. I mean,
Ethan spent almost the entire year
leading up to the CPS visit complaining
about the internet and how many crazy
haters he has. He even told the Giardia
story in an episode where he was
addressing those people. Ido's also
pointed out that there were members of
H3's own audience watching the story
live who were making comments about the
Klein household being covered in [__]
And the point of that shouldn't be to
say that one of them might have called
CPS. The point is that even Ethan's own
fans thought the story sounded a little
crazy. So, what do you think the people
who are not your fans are going to hear?
You know, the ones that the episode was
literally about, that Ethan must have
known would eventually see it.
Personally, I just don't give Ethan a
lifetime pass for saying whatever he
wants all the time. At some point, you
are somewhat responsible for protecting
yourself on the internet. And when
people say things like this, I think
it's a problem that you were that open
>> Ethan.
>> They're not saying that Ethan is solely
to blame. They're just saying he's
acting like a [__] But, Ethan's been
given the green light by everybody to
not only avoid any responsibility for
himself, but also just lie about what
happened. His claim is basically this.
He told the giardia story on stream in
February. A few weeks later, Badonkadonk
published this video about it, where he
maliciously lies and twists the story to
make Ethan look bad. After that, Denims
reacted to Badonkadonk's video on her
stream, but she didn't push back at it
enough and spread his lies to her
community. Her chat responded negatively
to these lies, and then almost all of
them started suggesting that CPS needed
to be called.
>> Almost all of them.
>> And Denims did not moderate or
discourage this behavior, and then one
of her viewers must have called CPS.
That's more or less Ethan's story. He
calls this the big CPS lie.
>> She participated in the CPS lie, child
protective service lie. I explained it
on the podcast, but the truth of the
matter is it's all a lie.
>> So, let's examine this narrative, and
let's start with who he blames most
directly for the CPS visit.
>> Denims endorses this clearly, as you can
see, that it seems like she's directly
responsible for CPS coming to my house
in the morning.
>> Directly responsible? What the [__] does
that mean, [__]
>> But, what did Denims actually do? Well,
she watched this video on stream, and
yeah, she expressed concern about what
she was hearing. But, expressing concern
about something you hear is not the same
as a call to action. It's not even the
same as endorsing that action. Denims
doesn't even mention CPS at any point
during her coverage, and she never
suggests a call to action of any kind.
She just says the story is concerning
and that parasites can be dangerous for
infants.
>> much like many other illnesses, it's
very, very, very dangerous when infants
get the same sicknesses that adults get.
>> Which is technically true, by the way.
But the point is that you can question
somebody's parenting and not necessarily
be saying that you think they deserve to
have their kids taken away. And that's
an important distinction
>> No.
>> because after Denims threatened to sue
Ethan for defamation,
>> No, Denims
>> he started denying that she ever
suggested
>> I acknowledged Denims had denounced
herself or anyone in her community
making contact with CPS, and I do not
believe Denims made a direct call to
action to her audience to contact CPS.
Obviously, right?
>> Okay, so now we've moved on from this.
>> Denims endorses this. She's directly
responsible.
>> And the claim is now that she
essentially primed her community to call
CPS.
>> The point is not that you instructed
your audience to contact CPS. The point
is that you propagated the false
statements that led to this incident.
You turned a blind eye to your chat
urging people to contact CPS. His kids
crawl around and eat [__] and her whole
entire chat saying to call CPS.
>> In his video about the CPS call, Ethan
shows a cutout of Denims' chat during
her coverage of the Giardia story. The
cutout shows numerous chatters
expressing concerns about the client's
kids, with some mentioning CPS. The way
Ethan presents this is as though Denims'
chat was universally responding this
way.
>> Notice the chat is almost in complete
universal agreement. Call CPS. Call
child endangerment. CPS. Social
services. Bro needs to unironically call
CPS. That's dangerous.
>> Oh, see, we've been over this a million
times. This is You guys I'm sure know
the ways in which this is a total
[__] lie.
>> Uh child endangerment, etc., etc. I'll
let the chat play for you, but you can
see just how crazed this community is.
And once again, this is Denims' chat,
and it's pretty much 100% of the
comments saying call CPS on them.
>> But what Ethan is showing here is in
fact not 100% of the chat. This is a
curated selection of chat messages that
Ethan got from this Reddit first. In her
response, Denims did the math and
between the first and last of the 65
messages that Ethan showed in his video,
Denims had had almost a thousand
messages sent in her chat, meaning the
messages Ethan showed as evidence of her
entire community being whipped up into a
frenzy were only 7% of the messages sent
during her coverage. And I also wanted
to point out that several of the
comments in that cut out, they don't
even have anything to do with CPS and
they're very similar to a lot of
messages from Ethan's own chat during
the GRDA story.
>> So, how crazy, man? This is his chat.
Stop smearing your poo on the walls and
you'll be fine. So, you guys are feeding
Sunny poop? Question mark, question
mark, question mark. Caca is just all
over the place. Ethan and Sunny and Jess
eat your poop? The kid ate the dog
poopoo somehow. No! For members, all
members. When Denims chat says it
though, she has to be thrown in [__]
prison. She has to be banned.
>> So, it would be pretty dishonest to
include these as evidence of wrongdoing,
meaning the actual total of CPS related
messages in Denims chat is even lower
than this. But, Ethan doubles down on
this point.
>> Great point. Great point. Great point. I
got to say, anyone that's been saying
stuff like that for like a year, very
smart. Very smart.
>> great false presentation the next day.
>> I'm not exaggerating when I say
literally every comment has called CPS.
>> Yeah, no [__] It's edited. I don't know
if Ethan knew this was an edited
selection or if he just saw something
that helped him out and didn't bother to
verify it. But, he immediately presented
it as fact and used it to bolster his
side of the story and he tried to stand
on it when he got challenged.
>> Love made a a good point. You said, is
this every comment? I believe this is a
live feed of the chat. This isn't
edited.
>> What about the top right? I I thought
these were
>> No, it's um this I think when you full
screen it No, this isn't edited. It's a
cut out of the full chat. It's just
enlarged there.
>> Oh, really?
>> Over the screen, yeah.
>> You know what? We'll just make it all
up.
>> We'll make the whole thing up.
>> We'll doctor the picture. We'll make it
up.
>> So, yeah, this was nowhere near her
whole chat. But, even if Ethan thinks
that Denims still should have moderated
better, which I can probably agree with,
there's a pretty big difference between
a failure to moderate and being causally
responsible for any subsequent action.
Denims does have an obligation to try to
mitigate harm, but failing to fulfill
that obligation doesn't mean that she
caused the CPS call. Denims didn't cause
the call, someone else did. So, when it
comes to responsibility, what's really
left? Well, some
>> Any lawyer who's been making that point
for like 6 months is a really smart guy.
I was
Guys, I'm going to do a quick show and
remind you to go and like the video.
>> And people claim that Adam Banata is
notoriously bad faith and malicious, so
Denims shouldn't have platformed him in
the first place. But, I mean, we're just
getting so far away from any true
culpability here. Like, what? Denims is
responsible for the call because she
watched a video from a guy who might be
known to lie, and then a tiny portion of
her chat responded to the lies, and
Denims didn't delete every single one of
them, and then days later the call gets
placed, which could have been anybody,
but we just assumed that it was Denims'
fault because I don't know. Like, is
this really the standard of
responsibility that we're going to hold
people to?
>> Yeah, it's just whoever you can spin an
narrative about. Denims had an narrative
spun about her, so obviously scum like
the Oreo are going to go along with it.
And cuz it's easy, cuz it's easy and no
one will check them. And like a like a
child molester basically all it takes is
like access and opportunity for for Nick
to to commit wrongdoing against someone.
So, they'll just do that. That's what
they do cuz they behave like child
molesters without the child rape, just
to be clear. I'm not accusing anyone of
raping kids, but they are they do behave
like child molesters.
>> At point, Denims is so detached from the
action of calling CPS itself, it doesn't
really seem fair to blame her for it.
But, you know what? Let's accept Ethan's
entire premise here. Let's say Denims is
responsible for not moderating enough
and for platforming these harmful lies
without pushing back. What are the
supposed lies? What does Ethan claim
Adam Banata said?
>> Don't you think you're being a bit
greedy with these go? All right, forgot,
Jewish.
>> Thank you for the $5, Dafoi. Thank you
for the $5.
That was false.
>> Denims uncritically, that's you, played
a clip of George Janitis, the human STD,
a person who Denims knows is clearly
biased against me and a prolific
spreader of misinformation. In the video
Denims watched, George Janitis, the
human STD, claims that there was dog
[__] all over my home, that I just leave
it on the floor. Okay, so first supposed
lie.
>> And we have to point out that again,
this is something that Ethan's own
audience intuited during the Giardia
story. Ethan also has a documented
history of talking about having a
>> Yo, that equals for the 10 New Zealand
dollars. Thank you. Thank you. Huge
appreciate. Thank you.
>> More.
>> Dog poop in the house.
>> My my dogs are not
>> So I this is part of the bit I saw
before I started. This bit's quite good.
This bit's quite good. Seriously, how do
[__] H3 fans even fight?
>> extraordinarily trained, right? They run
around, they play a lot. And sometimes,
especially the little dogs will go potty
inside. So admittedly, I'm my dogs are
not the best trained, right? I admit
that.
>> You think my fruit is bringing the
>> I think you're half correct.
>> It's half the fruit and the other half
is the dog [__]
>> Love Shredder and Alfredo. I do, but
I've stepped in their [__] multiple
times.
>> How many times do we get poop inside?
What's going on here?
>> Almost every day that they're here.
>> It was a delivery guy, he stepped in
[__]
>> But I I I
>> Holy [__]
>> Oh my god.
>> I stepped in [__] and tracked it all
over him.
>> like a super, how do you call it, like
strings, you know, from one of the dogs.
I just passing my foot over it and felt
a bump. It's old, by the way. It's hard.
>> So I'm sorry, it's defamatory to suggest
that your house was covered in dog poop?
Okay, moving on.
>> that my house is just covered in dog
[__] my kids crawl around in dog [__]
>> You kind of made it sound like that.
>> Olive has around, he's
putting everything in his mouth, he's at
that age.
>> Okay, next.
>> He intimates that my kids either eat dog
[__] or get in contact with it with
their hands.
>> No, actually, you intimated that.
>> It can go on surfaces and stuff, so
Olive chews everywhere, she's So Sunny,
had it, sense why he got it. You have to
ingest my poop.
>> That is literally you saying that if
Sunny had Giardia, he would have gotten
it from contact with poop-contaminated
surfaces.
>> That my children contracted a parasite
called Giardia from the dog [__] that is
all over my house.
>> Okay, even if the dog poop wasn't
literally all over his house, Ethan
consistently likes to pretend that it's
an evil snark narrative that his child
did contract Giardia.
>> It actually turns out when we got all of
the poop test back, he never had Giardia
even, and that's why they called CPS.
>> I can't I can't believe he just made
that up for no reason at all. Isn't that
crazy?
>> CPS cuz my 10-month-old baby had
diarrhea. Sunny's crawling around, he's
putting everything in his mouth, he's at
that age, he has Giardia.
>> He has Giardia.
>> So, I'm just kind of struggling here.
Where are the defamatory lies?
>> She believes his lies, his defamatory
statements. You did not disavow, you did
not disclose the credibility of Bat
Empanada, you uncritically platformed
and agreed with the statements that I
was putting my kids in danger.
>> You're talking about CPS, which anyways
to begin with, one I don't condone, two
I've never condoned it, and you will not
be able to find a clip of me saying,
"Yes, we should do this." because it
doesn't exist.
>> Just for the record, I don't think Ethan
deserves to have his kids taken away. I
think calling CPS over something like
this was pretty crazy, and I think he's
probably a perfectly fine dad. But that
being said, the malicious lies that his
entire victim narrative revolves around
are just things that he himself said.
And this is what Ethan does. He puts
things out there himself, and then if
you use them against him, he just calls
you a liar. He makes you uncomfortable
with his jokes, and then when you
complain about it, he says you're just
trying to ruin his life.
>> don't whistle at your You don't want to
say he cries out as he strikes you,
right, Kilo? Right, Kilo?
>> incendiary political opinions, and then
when you criticize him, he just says
you're probably a racist. He fumbles a
story about his family's medical
conditions, and then calls you a liar
for repeating it back to him.
Ultimately, one person is responsible
for the CPS call. Not his son, not
Denims, not Reddit. One random person
that Ethan will likely never identify
because CPS calls are anonymous. But
notice how this incident's been used.
Suddenly everyone who criticizes Ethan
is responsible for trying to take his
kids. Same thing with the skulls. One
unhinged person is now proof of a
coordinated attack. And this very
convenient framing is deliberate.
Ethan's been going after Hassan, Snark,
and anyone else in his crosshairs for
months. But I don't like what they said
about me doesn't play quite as well as
they tried to hurt my family. So now
every grudge that he already had gets
filtered through these incidents.
Remember that Ethan was already going
after all these people. The CPS and
skulls incidents just gave him the
justification he needed to escalate.